Ah, sorry.
Sorry, everybody.
Oh, wait.
Oh, that's my... Sorry, if I sound weird, it's because I'm on my recording... settings.
Okay, okay, I sound better now.
Sorry.
Okay, now, now I should be... Sorry, I was in my... I was in my recording... settings.
I forgot to swap, but now I am on the right one.
Now I'm on the right one.
But hello, everybody.
I'm back.
Hello.
Sorry, I've been... Oh my gosh, I've been, like, so busy.
I woke up... Well, I wasn't...
I didn't willingly wake up early.
Guess what asshole decided to wake me early today?
Guess who?
But... I haven't been able to record, like, late night.
Like, usually I record at night.
But that's when my voice is, like, super warmed up and, like... And I'm, like, usually have the time to record.
But I've been so fucking tired late at night because somebody has been waking me up so early in the morning.
And it's actually making me more like a morning bird instead of a night owl.
And it's... It's so weird.
I used to be, like... Like, you know, I used to stay up so late just working and stuff.
But I cannot... I've... I've been, like, hitting... Being, like, really fucking tired.
Like, at, like, starting at 1am.
Like, when it's 1am, I just have to sleep now.
Like, I just can't.
Because dad has been waking me up so early for walkies and food.
And so, like, it's been messy.
And I don't have... Usually, like, I would nap in between if he does that.
But I haven't had the time to nap these days because I've been so busy in between my streams.
Or, like, you know, before my streams, I have to do work stuff.
And then after my streams, I also have to do work stuff.
So, there's just so much stuff going on for June and July that I haven't been able to get any naps in.
And I've been mostly, like, working in the morning.
Which sucks because my usual recording time is at night.
And because I can't record at night, I'm only... I only have, like... Oh my gosh, I'm so close to finishing it, too.
That's what sucks the most because I'm really close to finishing my recordings.
But I've been stalled because some... Someone keeps waking me up in the morning!
That it's very hard to finish it at night!
Also, you know when I said he's grown smarter every fucking day?
He now knows.
He knows now.
He knows I don't turn on the bar collar.
He fucking knows.
It took him, like... It took him, like, five years.
But he's now knows.
He won the war!
Or six, sorry.
It took him six fucking years.
But he knows now.
He...
Because... Because this fucker tried to wake me up at five in the morning to eat food.
Because... When he was at the vet, the vet told me because he was sedated for one of his tests during his checkup.
Um... That... For me to feed him half of what he usually eats.
So... Uh... So, obviously, Dad was, like, extra hungry in the morning.
So, he was like, you know what?
I wanna be fed at five in the fucking morning!
And I was like, no!
And then, okay, you know what he does now?
He doesn't sleep with me anymore.
He doesn't, like, sleep in the bed next to me anymore.
Because he knows.
He knows that I will show him the bar collar if he tries to wake me up.
So, you know where he sleeps?
He sleeps outside in the living room.
And I have three beds for him.
But he sleeps in his other bed in the living room.
And then he barks at me at the comfort of his own bed.
So, I would have to get up and look at him in the eyes.
And say, no!
And he'll be like, you're already up anyway.
He's gonna be like, well, you're already up anyway, so you might as well feed me.
Because you got up.
I know you're not tired anymore.
I'm like, no!
Because I look at the time.
I grab my fucking phone.
And it's like, 5 a.m.
And I'd be like, no!
And then I'd go back to bed.
And then he keeps barking.
He's like, bitch, I know you're not sleeping.
I know you might as well feed me.
Since you're up, you might as well feed me if you want me to stop.
So then I was like, that's it!
And then I make him wear the collar.
Like, I don't turn it on.
I make him wear the collar.
So he thinks in his head.
And then, but then he realized.
Then I went back to bed.
But then he realizes, wait, you haven't turned this on in 6 plus years.
I'm gonna test my theory up.
So then, he starts doing little barks.
He's like, wow, wow.
And then, and then it starts to get louder.
He's like, oh, oh.
And then he realizes, wait, it's not on.
He, he cracked the code.
He tested his theory.
And it was correct.
And then, and then the moment it clicked in his head.
That's never been on.
He, he called my bluff.
And then he started barking louder.
And then I checked my phone.
It's 6 in the morning.
He let me sleep for an hour.
And then he was like, that's it.
I'm gonna crack this code.
I'm gonna call your fucking bluff.
And then at that point, I've given up.
I, at that point, I'm like, I, like he won.
He won the war.
I, I knew that was the only way to shut him up.
I, there was no other way to sleep.
I, I was so tired.
So, so I gave him his food.
And then I went back to bed.
I still kept the collar on him.
Just to see like, maybe like, he'll forget.
And then he wakes me up.
Two hours later, it's now 8am.
And he was like, you know what time it is, Doki?
It's Walkie's time.
And you think I, you think I forgot?
Like, you don't turn on this collar?
That's like, you're right.
I know now.
So...
Because he woke me up early in the morning.
I figured it's time to get some work done.
And do some of my recordings that I needed to finish.
Um...
Uh, yes.
And then I was telling my manager about it.
I was like, yeah.
Like, he knows now.
Like...
He has so much more energy than before.
Uh, before he...
I understand.
Like, I guess like, he has like, a new outlook in life ever since he broke his back.
Because he has so much fucking energy.
Uh...
Like, he would bark at me at random times.
I don't know why.
I don't know if it's for attention or he just wants to use up his energy or he's bored.
But...
I miss when dad would just sleep.
Ha ha ha ha.
All the time.
I...
He's...
He's trying to live his best life now.
I...
I remember the good old days.
When he was just sleeping.
Like...
80% of the time.
When I'm working or doing anything.
And now...
Now...
Now he's like, demanding me to do stuff with him.
Uh...
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha ha.
When...
When he used to not do that.
Uh...
Ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha.
Uh...
Um...
I miss when he was basically a cat.
But like, in a dog form.
That...
Ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha.
Um...
Anyway.
I'll tell my manager about how he just...
Uh...
He just...
He just wants to like...
He just has too much energy these days.
Um...
Especially when I'm super busy.
And then my manager was like...
Okay.
This might be a really...
Good idea.
Or a really, really bad idea.
And...
I was like...
What is it?
And he was like...
Maybe get another dog.
Ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha.
So...
And he was like...
Hear me out.
If there is another dog...
Then like...
Him and the other dog...
Might...
You know...
Use up all their energies...
Together.
So like...
He won't need you...
To help...
You know...
Help...
Get attention and stuff.
But then...
The really bad part...
Is that...
They might gang up on you.
Ha ha ha.
They might work together...
And...
Gang up on you.
If it doesn't work out.
So, double the trouble.
For them, it'll be double the fun.
So, um, and then, because, like, my manager was like, maybe you can get another wiener dog.
And I was, like, thinking, like, he's already really fucking loud.
If I get another wiener dog, it's gonna sound like a tank is living in my home.
And they both, high risk, high reward.
So, I'm just thinking, like, oh my, if they bark together, it'll sound like a fucking explosion in my apartment.
So, I thought about it.
I was tempted.
Because I was, like, high risk, high reward, you know?
I was, like, if it works, yay.
Yay.
I...
But if it doesn't work, I'm never sleeping again.
Nova, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Dad be like, I beat death.
I can live how I want.
Mr. Broken Bond, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Dad at the foot of bed, just staring.
Daring you to prove it even right.
Fado Guys, I really miss sleeping, guys.
I don't know what to do anymore.
I even thought about getting another dog.
That's how desperate I am.
I was like, new friend.
I'm like, maybe new friend will fix this.
That was how desperate I was.
I was looking for dogs at the... I was looking at the adoption websites.
Because I was like, I'm not getting a baby dog.
I cannot.
I cannot retrain.
I cannot train a baby dog.
I can't potty train something right now.
I can't deal with baby dogs.
Puppies?
Sorry.
I was like, what the fuck is a baby dog?
I can't deal with potty training a puppy and also going through their eating everything phase.
I don't know.
For those who are like... For those who like raised a puppy, not like older dogs.
Puppies go through a stage where they start biting everything.
Even walls.
Yeah.
The biting phase.
They would chew on walls.
They would chew on wires.
It's hell.
I don't want to go through that again.
Dad had that phase.
He started chewing on fucking walls.
And like eating walls.
And I... During that phase.
The teasing phase.
And I do not want to grow up with... I don't know.
I was like, I don't want to deal with that at the moment.
So like, I was trying to look through...
Like adoption websites.
Trying to find like, uh... Like, you know, like older dogs.
And like see if I could get like, maybe an older wiener dog.
But then I was like, silly me.
Why would... Like, usually wiener dogs do not get put in the pound.
And you have to get wiener dogs at like breeders.
Or like, um...
Yeah, like, you know, at... For breeders and stuff.
Because you'll never...
Because, you know, they're very expensive.
So why... They usually don't throw them...
Not throw them.
That sounds so fucked up.
Sorry.
That sounds really fucked up.
They don't usually put them up for adoption.
Because they're so expensive to own.
So...
There was no wiener dogs in the adoption website.
So I was looking through...
So it's usually allowed them just, uh...
Put them... Like, you know, you can only get them.
Um...
You only get them when they're like puppies.
Most of the time.
And it's like, when they are...
When they are in the pound.
They like get snatched up so quickly.
Or there'll be like hundreds of applications for wiener dogs.
Because, um...
Because of how the man...
Like how in demand they are.
Uh...
Golden Helm.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I have eight cats and a dog.
Pets are a pyramid scheme.
Don't do it, Doki.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um...
Lord Kurosus.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Female dog owner.
Thought process.
I am exhausted with one sassy dog.
Better get a second.
So I never sleep again.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
My thought process is that maybe they'll like loop each other to...
And then they'll get tired.
That's my thought process.
Like if they just like look at each other and they like, you know, just play with each other.
And then eventually they'll get tired together.
That's my thought process.
And then I figured out, like, wait, no, they'll just start ganging up on me because they know I'm weak.
Lord Kuro says, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
And second dog, does that mean we get another mascot?
Maybe.
I don't know.
This was, I was desperate, okay?
I was not okay when, like, my manager brought that up.
I was looking for any solution.
Like, at that point, they could make me do anything at that point.
I was so tired.
Sorry, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Just get a pet rock, Doki.
Easiest animal to train.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, this is really fucked up to say, but you know, like, those torture methods where you...
Like, there's actually a torture method where you deprive sleep out of, like, prisoners until they'll, like, agree to anything.
That's me right now.
Like, I'll say yes to anything.
That is, like, slowly depriving me of so much sleep that I'm very suspectable to anything.
Um, Ryan, thank you for the super chat.
That's why, that's why people... Okay, this is why, like, people are, like, torture doesn't really work.
Because, like, when somebody is pushed to the limit, they'll just say yes and agree to anything.
Even if, like, they didn't do it.
Because they just want the thing to stop.
That's me right now.
That... That is... That is me.
So, in that... So, like, in that way, torture doesn't work.
Because I would say yes to anything.
Brian, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's the same thought process that leads to some people having, like, four kids under four.
Yeah, but it, like, sort of works.
It sucks to be the firstborn, but, like...
You know, like, those parents who were, like...
Who are, like, oh, I can't take care of this child.
I... I... I... They're, like, oh, I want to have another kid.
But, like... Oh, I want to have another kid.
And then, don't worry.
The older kid is going to take care of the younger kid.
So, it feels like I'm taking care of one child.
Like, that's the thought process.
And then the mom... The parents would be, like, oh, that was fun.
Let me have a third child.
And then the secondborn will take care of the youngest one.
And then the oldest one will take care of...
We'll look after the two.
And then, and then the oldest child just has trauma the entire time.
So like, that's alright.
One, two out of three.
I was that kid.
Two out of three came out alright.
The oldest one might not.
And then, you know, they save money because they pass down, pass down like, like, hand-me-down clothes and electronics.
That's how it worked for Century.
Two out of three success.
Yeah, not the youngest though.
That's just, and then I'm, guys, is it noticeable that I'm an only child?
I didn't have to go through that trauma.
Yippee!
And then the younger ones will be traumatized and renecestable since they get, and never get anything new.
But yeah, I was planning on doing that before my dogs, you know?
Like, instead I'll have like, another dog, and then my older dad will just look after the younger dog.
And then, and then they'll tire each other up.
And then I hope that they don't learn to work together to fuck me over.
So that was like, my thought process.
So it could be a really good idea, or a very, very, very terrible idea.
Anyway, let's go play Splitgate 2!
I never had a chance to play Splitgate 1.
I heard a lot of things about both games.
Apparently, Splitgate 1 is the better game in comparison to Splitgate 2.
But Splitgate 1 is a much more dead game compared to Splitgate 2.
And there are some issues with Splitgate 2.
I thought it was funny that they added a Battle Royale portion to it.
Especially after the devs during the announcement for the game.
They were like, I'm here to make games better.
And, like, bring back, like, games like Halo.
And we won Titanfall 3.
And then he... I just thought that it was so funny that he was like, I... I won... I won Titanfall 3!
Anyway, we added Battle Royale in Splitgate 2!
I thought that was so fucking funny.
I was like, bro, look... Bro, what the fuck?
And why...
Wait, why...
Okay.
Maybe don't talk about Titanfall 3 if you're gonna add Battle Royale to Splitgate 2.
Like, bro.
Bro took 30 steps.
Pat.
Ozzy, thank you about Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The older child has trauma.
Ha!
Funny you say that.
What are the chances of you playing the common of Addy and Lele?
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um...
CB Miracle, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Dad's gonna train all his bad habits onto the new dog.
Happened over generations between my parents and grandparents' dog.
Since one was always older.
He was like...
He sees the new dog comes and he's like...
Bro, let me...
Let me tell you the secret.
Ha!
I've broken her and this is how you can do it too.
Um...
Thank you for the Super Chat, Miracle.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh...
Chicano, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, it's like...
When your older brother...
Um...
It took...
Uh...
When you're like in the same...
Um...
Class that was...
As your older brother...
Or sister.
And it's the same teacher.
And you know how some teachers reuse tests and stuff?
So then they'll be...
They'll like pass down like...
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, like Mr. Jacobson's class?
Yeah, bro.
Like this...
These are the tests in the syllabus.
Here you go.
I thought that was...
That was shit from like TV shows.
I didn't realize some teachers are actually like that.
Where they'll just reuse tests.
Because they're like...
That's alright.
There's only like two siblings in here.
Like...
I didn't...
But like too...
And then I thought about it.
I was like...
Oh, yeah.
I mean if I've been teaching for like...
15 plus years...
I...
There's...
I'm not gonna make like new tests every year.
I...
I mean...
And...
I don't...
Especially if like you're a public school teacher.
You don't get paid enough for the shit you have to go through.
Because kids are so fucking cruel.
Like...
It doesn't really matter.
They're...
They're already using chat GPT anyway.
Like...
Um...
But anyway...
Lord Crowe says...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You are now legally required to get a female wiener dog and name her mom.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You see, I thought about that.
But then, like, the thing is, I heard they still get their periods, even if they get sprayed.
So I was like, ooh... I don't want to deal with that.
Like, I... I... I don't... I... Ooh... They... They... Yeah, so... Yeah, even if they get... Yeah, so I'm like, Like, that's the female equivalent.
Oh, sorry.
Spade.
Sorry.
Even when they get spayed, um... They still get their periods.
Like, because I never owned a female dog before.
So, like, I've always owned male dogs, because my parents refused to get female dogs.
Because, like, my dad would be like, you don't understand.
They still get their... They still, like, bleed.
But then I was too young to understand what the fuck that meant.
Because I was like, I want a female dog.
And then my dad would be like, you don't understand.
They still bleed.
And I... I didn't understand what that meant.
Because I was like, what do you mean?
They still bleed.
So, like, I got... So, yeah.
So, I was just like, apparently some do.
They do not.
No, some... Like, there's a chance that...
Some actually... Actually do.
Wait.
But someone in chat was like, yeah, my dog still... Still bleeds.
Yeah, they can... Some of them can still bleed.
So, it's like... It's like, let's go gambling.
Because someone said in chat that, like, yeah, my... My dog still bleeds, too.
Even when she got spayed.
Um...
Um... They did it wrong.
The dog... The dog bleed.
Gotcha.
It's pretty rare.
Look, I'm not taking my chances.
Like, my luck has already been really fucking bad.
So, I am not taking my chances out there.
To be like... To still get to like...
To get a female dog.
That might still continue.
Because I don't want to deal...
I already have to deal with it on my own terms.
I don't need to deal with someone else's bleed.
I don't need to deal with someone else bleeding.
I...
Who hurt you?
Um...
Anyway...
Uh...
Doki, I think your dad lied.
I don't think you were the super chat.
Thank you.
No!
Someone in...
People in chat said that sometimes...
Like...
They...
They've owned female dogs that got spayed.
And still continue.
Like...
Um...
Uh...
So, yeah.
I...
I really...
I really don't want to deal with that.
And...
Um...
Yeah.
Google...
I...
Google says...
Weird.
None of my four generations have that.
Congratulations!
You won the gacha!
I don't trust my gacha luck enough, guys.
I...
I'm not taking my chances.
I'd rather...
My dog have no balls.
Than...
Because nothing bad happens.
Like, he's not gonna suddenly...
I mean, like...
Dad doesn't hump things.
So...
I'd rather deal with humping than, like...
I wake up and then my carpet's red.
And I'll be like...
Oh, no.
I don't want to win that gacha!
Um...
Dookie, you really want to be a bitch in the house?
Gladstone.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh...
So...
Nightmare scenario.
Yeah.
That's a nightmare right there.
Um...
But yes.
Anyway.
So...
Uh...
So that's why I'm not getting a female dog.
Because...
Uh...
Because, like...
I was...
I just don't want to deal with...
Lose...
Win...
Some people might say it's winning the gacha.
But I definitely feel like I'd be losing.
And it would be like a 0.1 chance to lose the gacha.
And somehow I'll still lose.
Uh...
Okay.
Anyway.
Sorry.
We had a long Zazzadon right there.
Uh...
I came for a split gate.
And got gacha.
Female dogs.
What?
That's once too many already.
That's...
That's once too many.
I don't have time to deal with that.
Like...
I barely...
I barely have time to deal with that.
And, like, fucking waking me up at 6 in the morning for food.
I do not have time to deal with that once or twice a year.
Like...
Okay.
We're finally gonna play split gate.
Sorry.
This is a...
This is a long tangent.
Uh...
I like how it's called Portal Wars instead of split gate.
Um...
Alright.
Let's just say disconnected.
Okay.
Retry.
Let me back in.
6 a.m.
A normal person's morning.
Woe is you.
I'm too young to wake up at 6 in the morning.
I became a content creator.
So I don't have to wake up 6 in the morning.
Let's see.
What's the point?
Alright.
200 friends.
Split gate.
More likes.
Laughy.
Thank you.
The super chat.
Alright.
Okay.
You know the moment I got to university?
I picked classes after 12 p.m.
Alright.
We do not need...
Okay.
I'll put it in medium first.
I tried once.
What it was like to take a morning class.
Never again.
I was like, I could do that.
I used to do that in high school.
Like, for like...
High school, middle school...
And elementary.
I could do that again in university.
I was wrong.
I dropped that class after 2 days.
I...
It's awful.
I was fucking wrong.
Okay.
Oh, I forgot to...
Where's...
What is this?
Horizontal sense zooms...
Okay.
God.
Give me a sec, guys.
I forgot to convert my sense.
Alright.
Split gate...
Okay.
Marvel rivals to split gate 2 sense.
Alright.
Marvel rivals...
Split gate 2...
800 DPI...
Uh...
What is my mark?
1.85...
Right?
Is that it?
I don't fucking know.
Okay.
2 point...
I think it was...
2.8...
Oh, yeah.
Alright.
You just Google that.
That's what I usually do.
I think 1.85 was...
1.84 was fine.
Just a little bit different.
Alright.
1.2.8...
Let's customize our binds.
Is there a...
Melee bind?
Inspect.
Ping.
Push to talk.
We'll do that.
Uh...
Aim down sight.
Okay.
Melee.
Here we go.
Alright.
I got all my bindings.
That should be everything.
Alright.
I don't know if sound guy is here.
But...
Uh...
Let me know if everything is okay.
Enable blood.
Accessibility.
Should be good.
Yeah.
Should be fine.
Okay.
Walk up.
Mantle up.
Jump over.
Woo!
Oh, I wasn't even done sprinting.
Alright.
Nice move.
Next up, portal.
Alright, portal.
Oh, wait for the new portal to unlock?
Oh, destroy it.
Oh, E.
Oh!
Okay.
Across the gap.
And then...
Oh, okay.
I'm thinking with portals now.
Wee!
Oh, close my portal.
Okay.
Ooh.
Okay, if I'm gonna...
Wait.
Okay.
Um...
I wanna do a new bind for that, actually.
Close portal.
Let's see.
I feel like...
I'm gonna do that.
I don't need to talk to people.
This is more convenient.
Ha ha ha!
And then, if I'm doing that, I think E should be my close portal then.
Um...
Emperor, thank you for the five gifted ships.
Thank you.
Alright.
Uh, yeah.
We don't need to talk to people.
Okay.
And then...
Yeah.
I like that more.
And then I wanna do that.
So...
Spawn a portal on the high wall?
Okay.
Oh.
Ha ha ha!
Get out of here.
I didn't see that melee part.
Eh.
I used G and sticky grenade it.
Okay.
Spawn a portal on the near wall.
And then spawn a portal through the bars.
Okay.
And then shoot the...
Oh!
You can shoot the enemies here.
Use your smart wall.
What's that?
Pick up the...
Oh.
Okay.
Voice chat.
Hold...
Why is that a tutorial?
What if I...
What if I just don't wanna talk to people?
Oh my god.
I had...
And they're like...
Talk to them.
Now.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha ha.
All right.
What was...
It was like tea or some shit.
I don't fucking know.
All right.
They're like...
You gotta talk to them.
Now.
Move to try.
Wee.
I did it.
You shall talk.
Socialize.
Mommy and daddy are worried about you.
Ha ha ha ha.
I don't want...
But what if I don't wanna pick my tea?
Mom.
Get kills at each point.
A career clash where you get to pick...
Oh.
There's me.
All right.
Let's try this game out.
And get like absolutely shit on.
Ha ha ha ha.
What is it?
I heard the battle pass was like...
Oh wait.
XQC, Tim, the Tap Man, and Shroud?
Moxie, Mendo, Nadeshot, Timmy, Ten, Skump.
Who's winning?
I feel like...
Okay.
Not gonna lie.
Shroud's team is like extra stacked.
Wait.
Tim's team's winning?
But then there's Tim.
Oh.
I guess like he has more...
I guess he has like more fans.
Yeah.
Overall, these guys have the most fans overall.
Because I'm like...
But it's Tim.
Like...
Ha ha ha.
Yeah.
I realize like he has more viewers overall.
Ha ha ha.
So it makes sense.
You know?
Oh.
But so it's Sound Guy.
Is everything okay with Sound?
Yeah.
It's just a popularity contest.
Shroud.
Okay.
Tim knows that he's Tim.
Like...
Like Tim...
Okay.
Tim, Naishat, and Skump are like what normies would...
Like normies watch.
Like those who aren't even like into gaming and stuff.
They watch Tim.
Because like he's really popular on YouTube.
Shroud, Tenz, and Timmy are like...
People who are into eSports would watch.
Ha ha ha.
And then...
XQC, Moxie, and Mendo.
XQC is like...
You hate watch.
Ha ha ha.
But also...
He has like...
What is it called?
I don't remember...
Like his fan base.
But there's more hate watchers.
Ha ha ha.
For this team.
Oh, juicers.
Yeah, I forgot what...
Because one of my friends used to be a juicer.
And I...
I judge him.
And it makes me realize how fucking young he is.
Ha ha ha.
He's like...
Yeah, I used to be a juicer.
I was like...
Ha ha ha.
Um...
This is like...
The normie...
Normies.
Esports.
And then...
Children.
Alright.
Uh...
Let's see.
Oh, is there like different...
Oh, there's different classes.
Wow, but you have to be brought up.
But guns are pretty close.
Okay.
Um...
I didn't know there was like different classes too.
I thought it's just portals.
Okay.
Audio.
Dialogue can be brought up.
I'll put an 82.
UI could be brought up.
I guess that would be music?
I don't know.
Gameplay is okay.
So...
We could just keep that.
Alright.
What are we?
We're...
We're weebs.
We're the most...
Normie, weebs, esports...
Normies.
We're just like a camara.
Like, we don't have like a place.
We don't...
We don't have a place.
We're like a mix of everything.
Because I've like hanged out with so many different types of communities.
I've like hanged out with like Normiesphere people.
I've hanged out with like esports people.
I've hanged out with like weebs, anime, because I'm VTuber.
So, like, we're like the most... We're like the normie VTuber gang.
Support date.
Oh, this says...
Wait,
I like health.
Wait, which one's meta?
Equipment recharges faster for you and your teammate.
I feel like speed boosts to movement reload and regen delay.
Oh, that's cool.
Let's try this first.
Aero is best.
Yeah, I feel like the speed boost might be good.
There's equipment too.
Oh, I need to unlock this.
Carbine.
Assault rifle.
Ooh, fire rate.
Let's try the car...
I don't know.
We'll try tempo first.
Which one's better?
Tempo or carbine?
Try them all?
I'll try the default first.
Tempo.
Oh, sorry.
Yeah.
Okay, I'll try this first then.
Alright, let's see...
How fucked am I?
Battle Royale?
24 player onslaught?
Oh my god.
Let's do the...
Let's do the arena.
Because like...
That's the classic, right?
The arena is the classic one.
I heard this game is very, very sweaty.
But like, the thing is, I'm coming into this game really late too.
So...
So I feel like I'm gonna get absolute shit on.
I don't know if there's SBMM or anything.
That's the...
That's...
That's the scary part.
I don't know if there's SBMM.
Oh, I'm the only Arios guy.
Wait, I don't know actually.
Because I feel like...
Oh, wait.
What the fuck?
What is he?
Oh no, is he Arios too?
Can't tell.
I can't tell.
Time for hot zone.
Hot zone.
Oh my gosh.
I'm gonna be so dis...
I don't know how to do portas.
I can't think with portas.
Time to go out there and show what you've got.
Whoa!
Smash it.
Move into the zone.
Secure it to score.
Oh.
Bye.
Zone active.
Whoa.
Oh
my god.
That's not fair.
Okay, there you go.
Teamate is attempting to capture.
What?
Oh, these are bots, aren't they?
There's no way.
There's no way these are real.
I refuse to believe they're real.
There's no way these guys are real players.
Yeah, they look like bots.
Oh, I guess because like, I'm starting now.
Oh my god.
Hello.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, it's the bat!
I heard so much about the bat!
Double kill.
Zone active.
Watch out.
Oh shit!
I wanna keep my bat!
Yeah, lamb beef prop?
Yeah, I know.
I know.
There's no way these are real.
Wait, how do I...
I don't remember how to break them.
There we go.
I don't know how to...
I heard the...
The bat is like, super OP.
Hello.
Oh shit.
There we go.
Oh, I should be defending.
Whoops.
I don't wanna be here though.
I don't know where the zone is.
Oh, there it is.
Don't worry, I've got a...
I've got a bat.
Boom.
Whoa.
Don't worry, they're bots.
I can do this.
Don't worry.
No!
That's fine.
Are my teammates bots?
There's no way Parry Stasis is a real person.
Is this like trying to figure out what my SPMM is?
I'm lost.
Where am I?
Okay.
They are all bots.
I guess because I'm like a new player.
So they're trying to figure out...
They're trying to figure out where am I?
Because I don't know why I'm in a lobby filled with bots.
I'm being lost on my own portal.
My own portal is making me lost.
Okay.
Hello, I'm here now.
Hello.
There you go.
Whoa!
I should use my abilities.
There you go.
Where am I?
I don't know where all my portals go.
Oh, shit!
Oh!
This is my first game.
Yeah, I think they're trying to assess where I'm...
Where my...
Um...
Where my ELO is.
For now.
Did she split the gate yet?
I'm so...
Okay, I'm gonna try it.
No, I wouldn't try the carbide!
What was my destroy portal?
Dang.
Oh, hey.
I see myself.
Alright.
Oh, shit!
Hello.
I got scared.
Okay.
Where am I?
Sometimes I don't remember where my portals are.
Oh, shit.
Yay!
I'm like, where did I go?
I don't remember my portals.
There's too many.
Yay!
Don't worry.
Woo!
Wait, I don't have...
Okay.
Oh, no.
I have no ammo.
Give me your gun.
There we go.
Oh, wait.
Is that Kraber?
Wee!
It's okay.
I have...
Oh, wait.
It's not.
Okay.
This is a fast-ass fucking rifle.
Wee!
Woo!
Whoops.
Hurry up.
I'll just keep making...
Yay!
Give me a sec.
I got a reload.
Yeah!
Give me your gun.
Woo!
Watch out.
Enemy is going for a capture.
Don't contest it.
What the fuck?
Okay, there he is.
On fire!
Oh, I have to go up.
There we go.
10 kills.
On a roll.
Give me your gun.
Double kill.
Kill.
Capture underway.
Oh, I do.
Oh, fuck!
Oh, my God.
It's fine.
Watch this.
Woo!
I still have that portal.
I'll always have that portal.
There's no way.
I was going to say, there's no way this bot kills me.
Wee!
Bro.
Yay!
Oh, my God.
That's sick.
Woo!
Oh, shit!
Okay, that was a...
You gotta admit, that was a sick shot, though.
You gotta admit.
That shot was pretty sick.
Guys, I'm...
Oh, my...
No!
I fucked it up!
No, my boy!
I'm so sad.
I'm so...
I forgot my portals!
He's going for a cap.
Might need an assist.
Okay.
I don't know why I was, like, single firing this.
I keep thinking it's, like...
I keep thinking...
Oh, wait, no.
This is the...
The tempo.
Wait, no.
Are they actually real?
I can't tell.
No, there's no way.
That's not a real person.
There's no way.
I'm not treating them like a real people.
Like, why is there, like, broccoli?
No way.
I was like, why is there, like...
Why is there, like...
There's no way.
But, like, why is there, like, steam name things, you know?
That's why I was so confused.
Like, the steam.
It can be.
They're not.
Yeah, but you see the steam icon?
That's why I got confused.
Wait!
There's no way.
There's...
There's no way!
They have icons!
I can't tell!
I'm, like, fucking around, too!
There's no way!
They have...
I'm broccoli-ed.
We are one round away.
There's no shot.
Why do they have steam icons?
There's no fucking way.
There's...
It's so...
It's so weird.
Please, don't you?
I just got off my 16-hour ship.
They get...
Holy, my...
I'm so confused!
I hope they're real.
Are they AI-generated steam profiles?
Oh, my God.
That's, like, crazy if they are.
That is so funny.
Bro, they, like, walked in, like, an army.
So, it could be fake.
Where are they?
A teammate is going for a capture.
Help them out!
Where?
New power weapon in the arena.
Can't tell.
I actually...
I can't tell.
At all.
Like...
It's so confusing.
Oh, I'm back.
Okay.
I don't believe they're real.
There's no way these guys are real.
There's no way.
Okay.
They're pretty bad.
I will never think they're real.
They're...
They're pretty bad.
There's no way.
It's fine.
You know, I'll fucking ego that.
Fuck it.
I refuse to believe.
They're real to me.
Okay.
Hell yeah, I am.
He has a shotgun.
That's not fair.
Where does this go?
Where do all my portals go?
I can't never tell anymore.
Wait, where?
Oh my god, wait.
What gun is this?
What is a Gravitaz?
What the fuck?
Did I kill him?
I can't tell!
Oh, I did!
Okay.
Oh, is it like a...
Oh, it's like a pusher.
Oh, I see.
It pushes people.
Wait, did he like...
Okay.
No, I was gonna say.
Yeah, it's like a shotgun.
I realized what it was.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
It took so long to kill.
Get out of here.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Whoa!
That's fine.
They're not real anyway.
Okay, Master Slider should be brought up a little bit.
Okay, I'll bring...
Is it just a Master Slider for audio sound, guy?
Hello?
I feel like I should use my portals more.
He's going for a capture.
Wait, where am I?
Oh, shit.
Don't worry, I figured it out.
I'm not used to playing with portals.
Heating up.
Wait, did they both capture a point?
Oh, shit.
I'm not playing objective.
My bots!
Capture the point!
Watch out, enemy is going for a capture.
Team!
You know I don't play objective!
No!
I wasn't playing objective!
Tim!
I was just...shooting!
I never play objective!
How do I talk to people?
Wait, is there no chat?
I can't chat!
Okay, that's it, I'm locking in.
Team.
Are you... are any of you real?
Ha haHaHaHaHa!
Oh my god, what the?
I don't know, I just want to know if they're real, you know?
Whoa!
That's the power weapon, I'm grabbing that.
I'm grabbing that, I believe in them.
No response.
They do not say anything.
They might not be real dirty.
I want to do that.
Oh, shit.
No, my bad!
Am I real?
Okay, the portal is shit.
Get that point!
Oh, my god.
I should actually use my nades, too.
Oh, my.
There you go.
Oh, shit.
Okay, there you go.
Okay, nice.
Alright, we're defending.
You got this!
Capture underway.
See you there.
Whoa!
Whoa, what the fuck kind of gun is that?
That's a shit.
That's a pretty sweet gun.
Nice.
Alright, we got the zone.
We did it!
Zone is active.
Alright.
Okay, I like this gun, though.
This guy's sweet.
Ten kills.
You're on a roll.
I've been detected?
How?
No, don't kill me.
I like this gun.
No!
My gun!
That was my favorite gun!
Wait.
Wait, is that my favorite gun?
No, it's not.
No!
Okay.
I just got here!
Oh, fuck.
What is my team doing?
Is that my favorite gun?
Oh, yeah, it is.
Where's the other zone?
Okay, it's down here.
Alright.
We got this.
Alright, nice.
Uh...
Okay.
My portal!
Here we go.
Here's my portal.
There you go.
I could be here.
It's fine.
I'm...
They don't know.
Okay, they might know.
They might know now.
Oh, my God.
Please tell me I have...
Yes!
There we go.
I actually...
Look at that, guys!
I actually played the objective!
Okay, now...
My next game has to be a real game now.
Yeah.
Nice.
Now my next game has to be real.
We finally won against the bots, guys!
We did it!
We beat AI!
Alright, let me...
Alright, my team is still trying to solve captures.
Alright, let's go to settings.
Uh...
Alright.
I'll raise it up a little.
Let me know if it's better.
Oh, change blizz.
Alright.
Now it should be real.
It's a purple class starter gun.
Oh!
Aw!
Wait, it's gun...
It's class...
Specific?
Oh, that sucks.
I wish the guns were for all the characters.
Cause I like the purple...
Okay, these guys have to be real players.
Like, who the...
Who the fuck would...
What kind of bot will willingly name themselves D-Die?
Wait, oh, there's a shotgun.
Okay, I wanna...
I like the assault rifle.
These guys have to be real now.
There's no way.
Who am I playing against?
Okay, yeah.
Somebody has like a photo.
Yeah, I...
You know Swagasaurus Rex?
I...
No AI can make that.
No...
No AI can have a name like Swagasaurus X.
That name is way too fire.
Power weapon inbound.
Yeah, they're real.
I hear them.
Whoa.
New power weapon in the arena.
Where?
Okay.
Double kill.
Zone capture.
Nice.
Okay, my team is still somehow better.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Oh, what?
Holy shit, my team.
Goodbye Swagasaurus Rex.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Sorry buddy.
Not cool enough, apparently.
Whoa.
Whoa!
No!
Slagasaurus Rex!
That was me.
Oh my god.
I was not paying attention.
I was confused.
I was not paying attention at all.
Cause I wanted this gun!
Alright, what's this?
No!
I just got this gun!
It gets swagged on.
I just wanted to use that gun!
It's so cool!
It looks so cool!
It would've been sick.
Alright.
Five.
Four.
Three.
Two.
One.
Yeah, this game is super fast paced.
But it is quick play, too.
I think there is SBMM.
So like...
So like, you're in the range of like...
Okay.
What gun is this?
Oh, it's not active yet.
Okay.
That's fine.
Oh wait.
God damn it.
I want to use this gun.
Bye.
Oh my god.
There's the gun.
Oh shit!
Oh, what is this gun?!
That one I picked up!
No!
Not Swagasaurus Rex!
I didn't know!
I'm so sad.
No, I'm pretty sure there's no SBMM matchmaking for it.
I'm pretty sure.
I'm so sad.
That's it.
Get out of here Swagasaurus Rex.
Get your ass out of here.
Oh.
Where did he get shot from?
Where is that cool ass...
No!
It's always Swagasaurus Rex!
It's always him!
That's okay.
We won.
He's on the hunt.
He's too flag!
I want to try the gun out!
We might be like, are you guys real?
There have to be real.
There's no in and are real.
He's so full of swag.
My ancestors still haunt me.
Also, let me know if this sounds better.
My ancestors...
They're always here to haunt me.
Heh heh heh heh.
Okay.
Oh my god, there's Swagasaurus.
I'm fucking coming for you.
I hear him.
That's fucking right, Swagasaurus.
I got you!
Wait, that's my favorite gun.
Oh shit.
Oh my god, get him before he kills me.
No, I can't.
They already despawn!
Okay.
Oh nice.
Nice, this is the gun I wanted to try.
No!
Oh wait.
Nice.
That was the gun I wanted to try.
Okay.
I think I just have to...
Oh god, he had a shotgun!
He had a fucking shotgun!
A teammate is going for a gun.
No, I had like the split stream.
The gun...
I don't know what gun it was.
Okay.
Oh wait, that's my teammate.
Oh!
Your opponent is going for a capture.
Yeah, you can't AD or some shit.
I noticed that.
Okay.
Where is he?
Oh my god!
Bro, he fucking beat me up!
Oh, I wanted to try this one.
Yeah, that was the gun I wanted.
I like this gun.
Oh my god.
But I have to reload.
I'm capturing.
Let me go.
I played objective guys.
Look at me go.
Yay!
I'm like still trying to figure out...
I'm still trying to figure out the portal stuff.
The gunplay is fun.
I like the gunplay.
But the...
The portaling is a lot.
It's a lot for my mind.
Oh, so it's like an L-Star.
The Phasma gun.
Yeah.
I'm still struggling to think with portals right now.
But I think the...
I am enjoying the gunplay of it.
The gunplay is really interesting.
Do they have a practice range?
Or no?
I just feel like they do.
Uh...
It's simple geometry.
But guys, I almost failed math.
Is it really simple?
I...
Guys, I didn't know what a whole number was!
The swaginator.
Sif dog.
Bad ping 6106.
3Q next.
Okay, it tells you which one's a bot.
Okay, so it does tell you who's a bot.
Wait!
Wait.
So like, are you trying to tell me the first game...
We had?
Wait a minute.
Does that mean the first game we had?
They were real.
There's no way.
There's no way they were real.
There's no fucking way.
I...
There's no way.
Those are real people?!
Holy...
There's no way.
But they didn't say they were bots though!
Oh, those are still bots.
Oh, thank god.
I was gonna go through something.
I was like...
If they were...
Like, cause this guy says they were bots.
So I was like...
I was gonna go through a lot.
If I found out they were real.
I don't know.
I feel like...
It's just...
It's just really sad.
Wait.
Someone else picked a bot.
Nice.
Oh, it's a...
Did we score?
What if bot was the clan name?
Okay, we gotta capture that.
Can I shoot my gun if I capture it?
Or no?
Intercepted.
They scored.
Let's get the next one out.
The bot was literally right...
Okay.
Just stole one from our base.
I was gonna say...
There's no way.
It's like capture...
It's basically capture the flag.
Yeah.
I'm gonna steal.
Oh shit.
Double kill.
They just picked up a ball.
That's fire.
I'm fucking running.
I'm running.
No!
Okay.
I knew her.
Oh my god, he's one.
Let's respond.
It's fire.
I got it.
And just stole a ball from your base.
It's fire.
They'll intercept, right?
They're all active.
Wait, can I throw this ball?
Or no?
No, I can't.
Your teammate just got a slip ball.
Please, teammate!
They're on the ball.
Let's get another.
Okay, that's fine.
The enemy scored, but that's okay.
I got a ball too.
Oh my god, we got two!
We got two!
We got this!
Here we go.
Boom!
Yoink!
My ball now.
I'm fast as fuck, boy!
Uh, I don't know about this game mode.
This game mode...
I guess I can hit people with a ball?
I don't know.
Five.
Four.
Three.
Two.
One.
Round two.
Alright.
Where am I?
Whoa, shit!
Aha!
Didn't get me.
I'm fast as fuck, boy.
Oh shit.
What the fuck?
Okay, we have one of the balls.
That's good.
Okay.
We gotta defend him.
Okay, nice.
Where is the other guy?
Where does this take me?
Oh my!
Okay.
That's not fair.
Ha-ha!
That's right!
This fuck doesn't know where I go!
It's not in his algorithm!
Oh shit.
Okay, if he was a real guy, I would have died like 20 times already.
There's a new ball.
Okay, nice.
Teammate just picked up a ball.
Thank god.
Thank god they're not real.
They're just AI.
Wait, they took one of our balls.
Give me my ball back.
It's fucking right.
Teammates, please!
Defend me!
Alright.
Don't worry, I'm here.
Don't worry, that's why I'm here.
Oh, watch this.
I thought he was safe.
JK.
That's right.
Can't get my ball.
Come on, get over here.
Oh, I like the movement though.
The movement is so smooth.
Wait, who stole it?
What the fuck?
He distracted me!
Oh no.
Bye.
Where is he?
I know you're here.
Wait, he died?
Oh fuck!
No!
He dropped the ball!
Oh no, we gotta steal it.
Oh, they'll have to.
We have to steal it back.
Oh no!
They're actually defending.
That's fine, I got one of them.
It's fine.
You don't know where I am.
They just picked up a ball.
Oh, he's right behind me, isn't he?
He's right behind me, isn't he?
Oh!
Oh, why is it so far?
Okay, none of...
Both teams don't have one ball.
There you go.
We both scored.
Okay, we...
That's fine.
Oh my god.
You guys are so annoying.
Oh...
Where is it?
Oh, it's over here.
The enemy just stole a ball from your base.
That's fine, that's fine, that's fine.
That's fine.
Oh shit!
Ah!
That's fine.
I got this though.
Yay!
We did it!
Oh, that was close.
That was close.
I...
I thought...
I thought we were gonna lose that.
Get balls!
Okay, wait.
Are you...
Are any of you...
Are you real?
I'll ask that until someone says yes.
I don't know!
I don't know who's real and who's not!
I can't!
Well done!
New split ball in play now.
Power weapon inbound.
Truly they...
One of them's real.
Jesus Christ.
I need to heal...
This guy in at chat.
Are you real?
Oh, where's the power weapon?
Okay, the food bar.
I'll try the food bar.
No, I'm not tall enough!
Too short!
I wanted to try the food bar!
No, I'm not letting that boss steal it.
That's fucking right.
Alright, you get the other ball.
I'll get this.
Okay.
Nice.
We got two.
Okay, I'm gonna grab this.
Okay, there we go.
I just need...
There we go.
Nice, I got the food bar.
That's a rocket missile, right?
I missed.
Are you serious?
Get back here.
Am I real?
Better question is if I'm real.
Okay, we'll try this gun.
What is this one?
I'm not real.
Oh no.
No, they stole two!
Oh my god, they're so lucky.
I'm trying to do this first.
That's the point.
We scored.
Let's keep up the momentum.
Oh, there's a charge up?
I don't like that.
I don't know.
I don't like that charge up.
Oh, I don't like that.
I don't like the charge up for that.
It's like so...
Yeah, it's so disorienting.
What's that gun cut?
The Borealis?
Borealis?
Right here in your kitchen?
Okay.
There we go.
It's hipfire is accurate.
Oh, okay.
I didn't like the charge up for it.
In this part of the country, at this time of the day?
Alright, let's try the...
Let's try the Battle Royale.
Change.
Alright.
I don't know what the Battle Royale is gonna be like.
But we'll see.
And that's what they added.
They're like, I wish...
I want Titanfall 3!
Anyway.
We just added Battle Royale to split K2.
I want games to be fun again.
Okay, I...
Wow!
Wait!
Hmm...
Someone here...
Is very familiar.
Okay.
Put it all out there.
It looks like a bot.
You guys think this is a bot, guys?
You think this is...
I didn't realize...
His name is in the A- At ChatGPT.
A dude at Helen Keller.
Ba-da-ba-ba.
Oh, is this a...
Alright, so what makes this a Battle Royale mode?
What?
Oh.
Oh, it's like guns.
Okay, I'm...
Oh, we gotta find guns and stuff.
Are they real?
Are any of you...
Real?
Are they real?
Hahaha!
Okay.
They are real.
Oh, there's an armor plate.
How do I use my armor plate?
Anyway...
What the fuck is my...
I don't know how to use my armor plate.
I do already have armor plate.
I wanna...
Go into this fight.
I'm mad.
Okay.
Yeah, these...
I don't know.
They were real.
What gun is this?
Ooh!
Bro, I don't know how...
What I'm looting.
I...
I don't know.
Like...
I don't know what I'm looting.
I...
I actually don't know.
I can't tell.
What's the drought?
Oh, there's a chest here.
Whoa, whoa!
Oh, shit.
Wait, is that...
Over here.
Okay.
They're not real.
There's no way.
These guys are real.
I refuse to believe they were real.
I am...
Literally just standing.
Okay.
The thing is, I don't know, like...
What some of these things do.
Am I supposed to go to the sanctum?
Where am I supposed to go?
Alright, lead me.
I have no idea where to go.
Lead me.
I can't believe Alan's a bot this entire time.
Like, what is that?
What the... What the fuck?
They're all lagging!
What the fuck?
Okay, they might be real because they were lagging like hell.
That was crazy lag right there.
Yeah, weird portal shit.
Wait, what?
What are we doing here?
The bots have a lag switch.
There's no way.
That shit was so fucking laggy.
Is there math?
Oh, we are at the end zone.
Okay.
Wait, are we at the end zone?
Where's my team?
By the way, Alan never answered.
Oh, you're right.
We'll never know if they're real.
We'll never know.
Oh, now.
Oh, my God.
The AI is learning.
The AI learned.
Okay, that's the shotgun.
Okay, I'll try that out.
Chat, are you real?
Wait, then how did Alan get into my game?
Oh, my God.
Is he also a bot?
But this is my first time playing.
Okay, there's no way.
Okay, yeah.
He's not real.
He's literally standing in the straight line.
Okay, yeah.
I think that Chicky Nuggies...
I have a feeling.
The Chicky Nuggies guy.
Oh, I don't like that.
How about this?
Wait, why is my...
Why is my heal so bad?
How do I regen heals?
Biome's closing?
Two teams remain.
Yeah, but one of them is...
Oh, wait.
Yeah, there's one full team.
Maybe the last full team is a real team.
Four to armor up?
Oh.
Because I have, like, two armors right now.
Oh, click four?
Oh!
What the fuck?
It doesn't even show up in my...
It doesn't show up in the notification thing.
You know?
Like, when...
Not notifications.
It shows up in the...
Oh, fuck.
My frames dropped to zero when I'm in here.
It doesn't, like, show up in the...
Oh, I want the deadbolt.
That looks like a cool gun.
It's next to...
Oh, it does...
Oh, it's that...
Oh, that's what the four...
I thought it meant I'm player four.
I...
I just thought that's what it meant.
I thought it was saying, I'm player four.
And I was like, that's me.
I am player four.
All right.
I have this gun.
That's fair.
Hello?
Any gamers?
We're gamers.
Gamers, where?
Is this a Kramer?
Oh, nice.
I mean, the map's cool.
I just wish there were people here for me to shoot my gun.
Jesus Christ.
How do I know where...
Wait.
Oh, my gosh.
Where am I?
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh, it's like you're portaling to four different locations.
I can't believe it.
I'm so sad.
What?
Did they leave?
What am I doing?
No, I just wanted to use that gun.
It's not fair.
Oh, my God.
I can't believe they died to the zone.
Can't believe it.
Yeah, they keep playing and keep...
Oh, my God.
How long do they keep...
It's like Fortnite all over again.
We have to play until...
All right.
We play until we encounter real people.
That's not...
That's the goal.
Surely we'll encounter real people now.
All right.
Teched out.
Where's our fourth player?
Why is there three of us?
Oh, there he is.
Okay.
Okay, we got our...
Bad decisions.
There we go.
We got our...
We got our fourth player.
I can't tell.
That's the thing.
It's so odd.
I can't tell.
Because, like, I don't know if I'm just encountering really, really bad players.
Or, like, if they're bots.
Like, it's so confusing.
Get ready to drop...
Are any...
Eventually...
Eventually, they'll let me know if they're real or not.
That's all I want.
I just want them to tell me if they're real or not.
That's all.
But, like, I just want some simp...
Something simple.
Why is that not real?
I can tell.
Whoa.
Okay, there we go.
Oh, no.
There we go.
I need armor, though.
Beating up!
How do we cancel portals again?
I don't remember.
How do we cancel other people's...
Why do I re-bind it?
Are they...
Are my teammates fighting someone?
Oh, I punched them.
Oh, okay.
Okay, I realize now.
Okay, that's a team.
Alright.
This guy is...
I don't have to think with photos with...
Oh, this guy is a...
Okay, that guy had to be real.
He was AFK.
I refuse to believe that.
He was a...
regular person.
Or he was, like, a bot.
A bot would never just stop moving.
Wait, where am I?
How do I get home?
Wait.
Oh, my God.
How do I return home?
Team!
My portal locked!
I'm so scared.
My portal got locked!
Oh, my God.
I'm so scared.
Oh, no.
I'm all alone.
I see them.
They're all...
We're all both trying to get to that...
Oh!
No!
I'm so sad!
Oh!
I went through them!
No!
I actually went through this red thing!
I didn't realize I could do...
And if I...
Wait, that's me!
Wait, how did I get back?
I'm gonna die here.
Fuck it.
Whee!
How did I respawn?
I was so confused!
I...
Okay, I'm gonna use the bathroom.
I'll be right back.
Good kill.
We're halfway there.
Way to...
Round two.
Double damage event is over.
Airdrop incoming.
Okay, guys.
I understand now.
I understand.
I...
Guys.
I understand now.
Okay, don't go through those random portal areas.
Because they can close down.
I get it now.
I...
I get it.
I was like, where did my team go?
I'm so confused.
He is!
Okay.
We'll drop here.
I don't fucking know.
I realized red means you can't go anywhere.
You're stuck there.
Okay.
Me get it.
Me get it now.
Okay.
Me understand.
What the fuck is this?
Wait, what?
I don't want to fight this, actually.
Wait, what the fuck?
We had someone die?
How did he die?
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Someone here.
I hear them.
Oh, my God.
There's someone here.
I know.
I really want to fight.
I see you.
I see you over there.
Oh, shit!
Goodbye.
I'm smarter.
Oh,
maybe he's smarter.
He might be smarter.
Oh, my God.
Hey.
Jesus Christ.
I'm getting out of here.
I need this.
My thing is still there.
My portal... Oh, it's not there anymore.
God damn it.
It was still there.
Oh, it's still there.
Okay.
These are real people.
These are actually real people now.
I'm actually fighting real people now.
I'm...
Yeah, no.
These guys fight like they're real players.
100%.
Oh, fuck.
This is bad.
NOOOOO!
There's too many players.
I have no more shield.
There's too many players around me.
I'm almost back, though.
Yeah, everybody's just there.
Like, I couldn't do anything.
Too many real... Okay, but I'm fucking gaming, though.
Fucking idiot.
I'm actually gaming, though.
I hear them.
Okay, I'm playing with portals for real this time.
Wait, what?
Where am I getting shot from?
I can't tell.
Oh my...
There you go.
I need the armor.
Okay.
Can we go back?
We can.
Nice.
Round two.
Drop frenzy event is over.
Okay, I know there's, like, people next to me somewhere.
Oh, my God.
No!
Oh!
I heard it, too.
I was like, I hear this.
I know...
No!
Come on!
Please!
Oh!
I could hear it, too.
I heard a person next to me.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
I was playing really well, though.
I will have to admit that I'm enjoying the game now.
Wait, can I?
No, I want to see my stats.
How the fuck do I see my stats?
Okay.
I did the most.
Look at that.
I know it's very hard to see.
Oh, there it is.
Look at that.
I fucking carried this team.
Look...
I think I'm...
I'm playing pretty well.
This world is closing.
Better move soon.
Wait, I had two bots?
That's not fair.
I only had one real person.
That's not fucking...
My bots did better than my real men.
That's not fair!
What the fuck?
Why did...
WHY DID MY FUCKING POSTS AT HAND?
That's so sad.
Okay, I'll- okay, I'm gonna try the...
Wait, uh...
How do I get to the main menu?
Jesus Christ.
Uh, okay, there we go.
I'm gonna try finding...
Uh, that's rough.
That is so rough.
I'm gonna- I wanna play...
Let's try if I can do, like, what's the 24?
They aren't slow.
That's too many people.
That's so amazing.
Let's see if I can find real players here.
Oh, I saw the Master Chief collection.
That's too many people.
Like, even in the Battle Royale mode, I was like, there's so many people around me.
I was- I was like, holy fuck, this fight is never-ending.
No, those were real.
The- the- when I had that non-stop fight, that- those people were fucking real.
They were, like, guarding my portal and everything.
A bot would not guard my portal.
I could smell the sweat.
Yeah, no, I fucking could smell it.
And I had to, like- I had to, like, basically shimmy everywhere.
Alright, let's check the arena out one more time.
I'm having fun.
This game- I like how fast the movement is.
I like the gunplay and the movement.
Um, I'm still trying to figure out how to portal.
I'm- I'm still learning.
Alright, let's go.
Yeah, it's very fast-paced.
I like movement shooters.
Movement shooters are always my favorite.
I just like moving- I like fast-paced games.
I just can't do, like, non-movement stuff.
Okay, is this zone?
Oh, wait, that's- I was gonna say, like, where am I?
I have too many portals out.
I don't know where my portals are.
There's too many portals.
I don't know where I place my portals.
Too many portals.
Where am I?
I still don't know where I am.
Where's our zone?
Oh, there it is.
Poor guy.
How do I get down there?
Wait, they captured it?
I don't even know where the zone is!
Oh, no.
I don't know where- I don't know where the zone is!
To the zone.
They're like, zone- I'm just like, where?
Where is it?
Oh, there it is.
Capture in progress.
Hold your ground.
I found out where the zone is this time.
I figured it out.
Oh, I see him.
Get shit on.
You're capturing.
Try to hold on.
Get shit on.
Now, time to pull ahead.
Capture underway.
Healer.
No!
I was healing!
Oh, my god.
My teammate got it.
Thank god.
Oh, I have to get the zone again.
Oh, my god.
That's not fair.
That's not fair!
There's three of them!
Oh, yeah.
You win a 1v3.
You're so good at it.
You won a 1v3.
Where's my teammates?
Where is he?
Oh, nice.
There they are.
Come on, team.
Good teammate.
We're so...
Keep capturing.
You got this.
Yeah!
That's right.
We're better.
We're fucking better.
Let's go.
Let's fucking go.
Every...
Every one...
Like...
Uh...
Kill Alan got off of me was a 1v3.
I...
I won an actual 1v1.
Twice.
Two.
One.
Round two.
Yeah, his ass can't win a 1v1.
Exactly.
Where is it?
This way.
Where is the zone?
Oh, it's over here.
Wait.
Where's the zone?
Oh, my God.
How do we get there?
How do you...
Oh, it's...
I'm so confused of, like, areas.
I was so confused.
Oh, no.
Are you serious?
Killed so many!
Oh, my God.
Oh,
my God.
Okay, though.
That was a good aim.
I killed, like, three!
Yeah!
Let's turn things around.
Okay, I'm grabbing this.
Are you serious?
I'm trying to grab this.
Oh, what's trying to kill me?
Worth it.
So worth it.
Watch out.
Enemy is going for a capture.
Oh shit.
Oh shit!
No!
I didn't see him!
I didn't think he would go through the portal!
That was a good play.
Wait, what?
Who shot me?
Oh my god!
I didn't think he would go through the portal.
I wasn't expecting that.
This guy's good.
Where's the portal?
Okay, there it is.
Nice.
It's 1v1 now.
Oh my god.
He has good aim.
He also gets like first shots too.
Which sucks.
He has first shot advantage.
Haha!
Oh fuck!
No!
God damn it, it's okay.
My team's here.
Double kill!
That guy's really good.
He's actually really annoying.
Watch out.
Enemy is going for a capture.
Okay.
I'm hoping... Oh my god.
I have to be down here for a sec.
Heating up.
Okay.
Oh no.
Nice!
We got it!
Yes!
Another round!
Stay shot.
One round at a time.
Oh.
Haha, I'm playing so well.
Oh, that's right.
I win every 1v1.
I just got the aim.
What can I say?
Oh, he does.
Oh, shit.
Where is it?
Oh, my god.
Oh, bro, what the fuck?
Why is he... Holy shit, you're so bad!
Oh, my god, he's so bad.
No!
Oh, my god, I was playing so well.
Holy shit.
Are you serious?
Oh, my god, I've played so fucking well, too.
I killed so deep.
Please!
I can't do everything!
Oh, my god, who shot me in the back?
Oh, I got shot in the back.
I was actually playing so fucking well.
It was crazy.
Oh, my god, I can't.
There's too many people.
I don't think we're gonna get this round.
My team is sandbagging really hard.
Unless, like, I can 1v3 all of this.
I can't.
My team needs...
I need my team to help me.
Oh, my god.
My team.
I was practically splitting solo.
Oh, my god.
Guys!
Team!
Come on!
My team is sandbagging so hard!
They have two real players!
I'm literally at, like...
I have 45 kills.
Zone is high.
Opponent is going for a capture.
Power weapon inbound.
Okay, I have to, like, be careful.
Alright.
Wait, what?
Oh, my god!
I didn't realize there was...
I didn't realize there was a door there.
That was...
I'm so...
That was my bad.
I actually played really poorly there.
I didn't know my map there.
I actually got shit on because of it.
Oh, my god.
Okay.
It's fine.
We got the...
We got the zone.
Oh, I got two kills.
That's fine.
Okay.
I got the bat.
Zone active.
I think the hard part is that...
What?
Bro!
Jesus Christ.
He's that guy.
Oh, my god.
I got the gold thing.
Okay.
I can't...
Oh, no.
There's two of them.
I can't do anything about it.
Oh.
There's two of them.
Of course.
I backed a 1v2.
Yeah, that's fine.
Oh my god, of course.
Of course, I had to slide into another person!
Oh, fuck.
My team is like struggling so hard, though.
They're actually struggling.
I don't know what to do.
They're struggling right now.
Oh my god.
Oh, fuck.
I tried to guard.
Oh my god, they're actually like...
Oh, I don't know who got it.
Yeah.
They're like playing like as a team.
My team's trickling in one by one.
My team's just trickling in.
Holy fuck.
Team, please!
I'm carrying you all on my back!
No respawns?!
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
I think I'm fucked.
I think I'm fucked here.
I rely on respawn.
Oh, fuck.
I need regen.
No!
They chased me!
I was the last teammate!
Oh, I knew it!
Oh, my team.
I just think it's my team.
Yeah.
I didn't realize that was the last one.
It was actually a team diff.
Yeah.
No, they had... My team was struggling so much.
I literally like doubled their damage.
I don't know how they died!
Look at their deaths!
They... I... How did I die last?
Oh, my God.
I was literally flanking, too.
I was literally flanking.
They were even... I don't think they were trying... No!
They were not trying!
There's no way!
Okay, I'll do the last one.
Okay.
I was playing really well and then like my team kept like...
My team was actually fucking sandbagging me.
At one point, I like... I like fucking had like a 1v8.
I had... I had a 1v8!
And my team wasn't there!
I don't know what happened to them!
Like... Where was... Where was... I was killing eight people and then like...
My team just never showed up!
It was... I was so confused!
Sandbagging me!
They just... It's like nobody showed up when I was 1v8!
Oh, yeah.
Ducks are not in the team.
Yeah, I was so locked in.
Cause like...
They just... They just kept coming and they just kept coming and they just kept coming!
And they just won't stop!
Like... I was so locked in cause they never stopped coming!
I was so confused!
Don't waste it!
Oh, it's planting?
Between planting the firecracker or defending your base.
What do I plant?
Power
weapon inbound.
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
I...
I don't... I was like...
I didn't think they were all gonna show up.
How do I plant?
I don't know how to plant.
I was...
Okay, nice.
Oh, what?
I didn't get the...
Triple kill.
Oh.
Okay.
This is such a weird game mode.
I don't know if I like that game mode.
It's so weird.
There's a bat.
Ah!
Damn!
Aw, wait!
They defuse so fast!
I thought we had more time to defuse.
That's crazy.
Yeah, the defuse was so fast.
I wasn't expecting it.
I thought we had more time there.
So I wasn't...
paying attention.
At all.
Oh, I'm a dead here.
I'm dead here, I think.
I'm trying to like...
Throw my ball away.
Whoa!
Wait, who...
Did we plant or they plant?
I don't like this game mode.
In general.
This game mode is so confusing.
Not gonna lie.
Like, I'm so confused.
Defuse?
Again?
Guarding it!
Firecracker taken.
Okay.
Okay, I'll go guard.
I'll guard.
Fine.
I'll try guarding.
Oh, it's a loop until it works.
Oh!
Okay, I get it.
Okay, I understand now.
I'll try.
Dude, defending it takes so long.
It takes so long to defend.
Double kill!
Okay.
Triple kill!
There we go.
We should win this one.
It's literally two seconds.
There's no way I can defuse this time.
Thank God!
Yeah, I don't like this one.
This game mode is, like, not great.
I don't like this game mode.
Uh, bro, this guy...
This guy's a bot.
I realize what the AI bot profile pictures look like.
It's like this.
This is what they look like.
Yeah, I don't like this game mode.
Five.
Four.
Three.
I think, like, this game mode is not that fun.
Round two.
We are defense.
Defend our base.
Okay, where's the...
Double kill!
I sort of understand the portal now.
Power weapon inbound.
Where's the power weapon?
Fire tracker in the ground.
I want the power weapon.
Clock is ticking to defuse it.
Wait, where is it?
Oh, it's down there.
Oh my god.
Okay, it's down there.
How do I get down there?
Wait, I didn't kill that other guy?
Oh, I thought I did!
He was so low!
I thought I killed him.
I wasn't paying attention.
Oh my god, we gotta help him.
We gotta help him.
Nice, we did.
Yeah, the defuse is so fast.
It's actually so fucking fast.
Look how fast that defuse was.
I have my turn.
Oh shit.
What the fuck?
Not my turn!
Yeah, it's way too fast.
I think the defuse.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
What the fuck was that?
No!
I have to reload!
Fuck!
I have to reload.
That sucks.
I have to reload again.
No!
I have to reload again!
I need to remember I have a sidearm too.
You're right.
I have a sidearm.
Okay, we have...
We're...
We're guarding the plant.
There you go.
There has to...
There's someone here.
There you go.
Okay, I know the melee now too.
I need heal.
But I go back.
Nice!
Alright.
I'm getting better though.
God, I love the movement.
Oh!
I love the movement though.
The movement's fun.
The movement's really fun.
Yeah.
It's just like...
I wish you could pick the game mode.
Because I really don't like this one.
I like the movement and like sometimes the guns.
Depending on what gun I have.
It's not feeding time.
It's like two hours.
That's the thing.
He like...
Oh.
Oh no.
I don't wanna plant.
But my teammates are dead.
Okay.
I'm gonna go...
I'll plant here.
I'm gonna plant.
Oh my god.
And it takes fucking forever to plant.
Holy shit.
It takes so long to plant.
Oh my...
I thought it'd take a lot faster.
But that takes really long time.
That's actually crazy.
Yeah, it's not a fair game mode.
For sure.
Oh, I don't have a port on the other...
God damn it.
I thought I had a port on the other side.
Okay.
My team planted.
I don't know if they'll defend it.
Dad, please!
Oh my god.
Fuck.
I have to reload.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna look from here.
Okay, it's five.
That's five.
We got it.
Yes!
Holy fuck!
Oh my god.
I played out of my mind there.
I played...
I played really well there.
Oh.
No!
He just wants to be fed early.
He wants to be fed like...
...three hours early!
Oh my god.
Yeah, he's getting...
He's getting...
He's getting closer now.
But that was fun!
Okay, I actually enjoyed that.
Like, the more I learned...
The more I learned the game, the more fun I definitely had.
And I definitely really enjoyed the movement part, the movement shooter part.
And like, the gunplay sometimes.
Sometimes the gunplay.
But yeah, the movement's really well.
Portal-wise, I still don't know what I'm doing.
I think I'm like, slowly learning how to portal.
But like, I feel like I still sort of don't know what I'm doing.
But the movement's pretty solid.
But that was really fun.
Again, Zekra, thank you in the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, I think I was like, my aim was carrying me throughout that, not gonna lie.
I think I won majority of those fights because of my aim.
I think it was definitely like carrying me.
Like, I might not know what I was doing.
But like, as long as I could put my crosshair on a person, like I was making it work.
I don't know if this game should be a battle royale.
No, the battle royale portion of that was so confusing.
But, cause like, the fact that like the portals couldn't close was so bullshit.
I was like, are you fucking kidding me?
It closed?
My entire team is like in the other arena.
And the only way to get back is to find another green portal.
But yeah, thank you all for joining.
I would have done a longer stream today.
But I want to do a long stream for the Halo stream.
So I'm gonna call it here, here.
So I can have a little bit of break before we go to Halo.
Hey guys, as always everybody.
Stay hydrated, posture check.
Get a move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, stay up for a little longer.
Cause I'm starting my first Halo series.
Like, I'm starting my first Halo game.
And starting my first venture into the Halo series.
I've never played Halo before.
A campaign.
I'll say I never played Halo campaign.
Cause we played Halo Reach, was it?
Multiplayer together.
But I've never played the campaign series.
Cause I never grew up with Halo.
So I'm starting that for the first time today.
So yeah.
I'll definitely play Splitgate in a member stream with all of you guys.
Maybe do a custom lobby with all of you guys.
Hey guys.
I'll see you guys later, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!